hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch today Jason Momoa made
a huge mistake while filming Aquaman
from my favorite talk show the Graham
Norton Show let's face it he's the best
there is in the business people actually
coming back from the John Campea show
and on my way to there I was listening
some grab Gordon interviews because he's
getting that warm-up interview vibe even
though I wasn't been interviewed before
we go into this I wanted to give a
patron the day shot at the top of this
video to a man named Scuba Steve Scuba
Steve has been a longtime follower of
our channel and he's been a longtime
loyal patronage act as well and as you
guys can see here he does this awesome
graffiti artwork both John and I follow
him on Instagram and I really hope you
guys can follow him too I want him to
keep on keeping on with the art and so
please show him some support give him a
follow comment tell them the real
rejects and yeah he'll reply back to you
thanks guys anyway we're gonna watch
Aquaman on well I'm gonna watch Aquaman
on Saturday a dogs going out of town for
a few days he's a dick cuz I want to
avoid it at all costs ya gotta get out
of town for Aquaman because I hate DC
hate him that'll be great for the
comments
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
TV see much but they just they gotta see
movie lately
[Laughter]
Wow you know I don't think I've ever
really paid attention today Sumomo
interviews seems like the nicest guy but
he seems like he's having just a
complete blast because even his
mannerisms are different than I would
have expected I mean around kind of like
this like shy like happy to be here kind
of guy and he just seems like a really
sincere dude he seems like the total
antithesis to a typical Hollywood
personality and most of his characters
he's played on screen yeah very cocky
confident guys what a silent menacing
dude we've seen him here okay I could
see why would the look he gets typecast
a certain way it actually makes it even
cooler to see how I mean we haven't seen
Aquaman yeah and a lot of people have
but to see that in Aquaman he really
gets to let his personality like more of
his real personality shine through which
he did in Justice League but even more
so in Aquaman that's that's really cool
that he gets to let that side of him
really be revealed to the world because
yeah you know I see a lobbyist Graham
Norton it and show interviews and well
it was kind of taking me back here was
how he was so interactive with the
people on the couch Graham Norton's
asking the questions but he's looking
directly at like the lady next to him
yeah and you grant as well he's really
involved with that conversation with
them that seems like very humble about
him I wonder if he's still like that
seasonable I don't know this interviews
old there was something pretty cool to
see very personable side of Jason Momoa
yeah Man 1 I thought it was cool too
then they touched on his tattoo and the
idea that they sort of built that into
the character and kind of took that like
I always associate Aquaman as being a
law
white guy yeah and so you know from the
trailers and from that little snippet of
information I just think it's cool
they're bringing that cultural aspect a
little further into the movie I saw just
recently they had the premiere and he
did like a haka on the carpet and stuff
like that yeah really honoring his roots
yeah yeah yeah just see yeah like I'd
like you said he just seems like a
totally fun cuddly guy which I was
totally taken aback this makes you want
to hang out you know is my brother went
to Australia they took like a certain
group of people to brought into
Australia fun to be on the Aquaman set
and I think he's like has a vlog coming
out for that I don't know if he got any
of this on camera but he said out of
anyone over there and the Cepheid spent
the most time with them and it was just
very interactive and personable was
Jason Momoa oh that's cool like the star
of the movie was just like legit just
kickin it with them and just talking and
more than just high-energy personality
guys like he's just really chill relaxed
guy oh man I want to be him well just
grow your hair out I just want to be
this guy look at it man this is so cool
keep working out you know keep growing
your hair keep growing your beard and
pretty soon all you'll need is a tribal
tattoo from your Filipino roots yeah and
you'll be Jason Momoa - I guess my other
takeaway is Hugh Grant's very old now
yeah he I feel like Colin Firth in the
older age is winning now because like
Colin Firth was a bit stuffier than Hugh
Grant Hugh Grant was like young and
charming now that they're both aging I
feel like calm first kind of edged him
out not to disrespect you grant I think
he's still sharp you know he made me
laugh in this interview but yeah this is
the first time I was like oh [ __ ] he's
getting on you know well I think it's
because Colin Firth has always sort of
demonstrated some level of range and
managed to break out with like he had a
pretty hot year with the King's Speech
and Kingsman yeah back to back Hugh
Grant always had that career of you know
sexy charmingly befuddled leading
romantic comedy man and you can't just
age your way through after a while like
it but you start looking old you guys
are I know he's like in the Paddington
movie or something like that okay yeah
well cuz everybody British isn't
and I don't know what he was promoting
at this time what iPad isn't what what I
hope is that you grant can make a new
chapter his career basically doing the
British version of what Liam Neeson did
yeah so you get like what starts out as
a romantic comedy then becomes a revenge
thriller and then we've got the the Hugh
Grant revenge movie genre and with like
the very brief little bit of knowledge
about Jason Momoa
it kind of makes sense why he's such a
humble guy a Hawaiian so he's obviously
got that really chill personality he
didn't even like set out to become an
actor like he was supposed to became
like a model randomly like 19 years old
I wonder why yeah like 19 and then
somehow landed his way into acting so
those kind of guys who remain humble I
feel like when you're young and you want
to be an actor and you go without that
path that's usually when the cockiness
kicks this is a verification of all your
ambition yeah you just trip and fall
into a modeling career that man I love
this guy I can't wait to see Aquaman
excited man and he is a big part of it I
mean his acting has oddly sort of
increasingly impressed me over time you
know Khal Drogo I was like all right
sure but anybody could probably do that
and then I saw on yeah we could have
well anybody big and sexy could do this
Joe Manganiello could probably then I
saw weirdly a movie I didn't like which
was called the bad batch but he led the
[ __ ] out of that movie and I thought he
was really good so like he's he's grown
on me a lot beyond just his likability
over time so I'm really excited to see
him lead Aquaman and when Aquaman's a
huge success would become a cocky
[ __ ] and ruin all these things we
said about him oh yeah yeah break up
that family you know start cheating you
know drug habit all that sort of stuff
it's gonna be great all right guys well
thanks for tuning in would you lick
Jason Momoa as nipples yes
comment down below you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check out
Scuba Steve over on his Instagram page
thank you